foreign
Ty developer even silicon Valley's
biggest conglomerates have begun to take
note of charge gbt versatility and
practicality people have started earning
money through chargeability and some
even predict the Revolutionary AI
chatbot will replace Google search but
what makes charge ability so resourceful
what chippity is and how it works and at
the end we will discuss some of the ways
that chair GPT is being used the real
world the potential implications of this
technology from chat boards to language
translation charitability has many
applications that make it easier for
businesses and individuals to interact
with technology so hello everyone I am
mank and welcome to Simply learn make
sure you are subscribed to our Channel
and hit that Bell icon to stay updated
with the latest technological Trends
before we move on to the demo part let's
discuss what chargibility is and proceed
further for the same so what is charity
charitability is positional language
model created by open AI it is a form of
generative preteen transfer gbt model
which was trained on a data set of
conversational prompts such as dialogue
Snippets and chat logs the model is
capable of generating human-like
responses to text input so now let's
understand how chargpt actually works
this model is pre-trained on a large
type data set and then fine tune on a
smaller data set specific to the
everyday task when the model receives
input from a user it uses the pattern it
learned during fine tuning to generate a
response let's take another example the
model can generate an appropriate
response even if the input is not a
complete question or a sentence after
seeing what is chargeability and how it
works now moving forward let's see how
we can use shared GPT in our day-to-day
life
so this is a Google search here we will
write
chat dot open AI
dot com slash chat
it will take time
so this is the chat window UI
objectivity
so our first use case is chargpt can
explain complex subjects okay so first
we will ask like what
is neuroscience
it will take time
it's taking time to load because many of
the users are using
where it started Neuroscience is the
scientific study of the nervous system
which includes the brain it will write
all about the Neuroscience you can ask
anything any subject okay like Heart to
Heart easy any or even you can stop
generating two if you want to
okay so this is how you can ask like any
question to the any complex question to
charge everything okay uh we'll ask one
more like what is
quantum
it's loading
I don't know why it's taking time
because of net issue or I don't know why
take time and it will come
that uses properties of quantum
mechanics to perform operations on data
like this okay
two states zero or one and all the
content Computing knowledge
okay
so this is how you can ask anything like
any about any complex subject to the
charge ability okay
so with chat our Second Use case is we
can write code using chat GPT okay we
can write so here I will give give me
a machine
learning
program
for
population
okay press enter
okay so here it's starting there is a
simple Python program that uses scient
Library there's this and this
this is how you can take write a code
any code if you ask anything like
sorting like add two numbers I've or
palindrome
anything you can anything you can ask
from chargeability it will give you a
code proper code
edit right please note that this is a
simple example of sort prediction is a
complex task and this example is not
enough to make a good prediction it
would need a lot more data feature
engineering and model tuning to make
accurate prediction Okay so
let me give another Java
implementations implementation
of the what bubble
algorithm okay
let me ask this
yeah it started like here is the Java
implementation of the bubble sort
algorithm
so if you proper runnable algorithm
okay like bubble sort
of give you full
you can ask any type of code any type of
like apis anything
it will explain to this implementation
using nested Loop to compare adjacent
elements in the area and swipe them if
they are in the wrong order
okay
and then after the outer loop completes
the array will be sorted in ascending
order our third use case is we can debug
the code okay so for that
but I will I will take this one code
okay
I will take this code
and
here I will write debug the code and I
will paste it here
and what I will do I will instead of
temp
here
I will like I will write
okay I will add 2p okay so now
what it will do charge but it will do it
will debunk see the error in the code is
in the this line
okay
TMP it should be temp
you can see here
it is stamp
so from charity you can debug the error
okay you can have the conversation with
to pull the charity like if you have any
question you can directly write what's
wrong in the other question and like
this okay like you have an extra p in
this variable name which is causing a
compile error this is because temp is
the variable that you declared earlier
to store the value of current element
whereas temp is not a variable that has
been declared so here you can see
the stamp is declared here so that is
that the error is causing the code not
to run once you fix the issue okay like
sort the arrange or sending audio
okay so using chat GPT you can easily
debug your errors the code and it is
very helpful on your project building
okay so fourth use case is you can
create custom marketing plans or a
strategy okay I'm repeating again you
can create custom marketing plans or
strategy like how so here I will write
how
could
remote
videos
on
social
media
okay
present
it will give you proper plan how you can
promote your YouTube videos on your
social media
okay
I will chat with this okay I will ask
some question
engagement everyone knows there are a
few strategies you can use C per second
and more like more to come like share
your video on personal social media
accounts include your Facebook Twitter
Instagram and other accounts thing like
that join the event communities and
groups through your social media ads
platform like Facebook and stuff
Instagram and Twitter
collaborate with influencer it is also
true create a hashtag for your videos
use YouTube video built-in sharing
feature
it will give you all the marketing plans
it can create marketing plans any type
of plans
see remember your video should be
engaging information and should we
provide value to our audience
it is something like that now I will ask
one question to chat gbt Okay so
I will ask what
if
make
only
travel videos
okay
what if I will make only okay
travel videos
so how
should
I
capture the
audience
you can ask any type of question okay
relevant to this question or this answer
you got
okay now let's see
it will give you everything if you are
making travel videos there are like few
strategies you can use to capture and
engage your audience
like this okay so the unique interesting
aspect of the destination you visit
people are often drawn to new and unique
experience like say share your personal
experience and insights it will give you
a proper plan
like how you can increase your audience
engage your audience okay
collaborate other travel bloggers it's
through engage with Audience by
responding to comments messages through
remember your video should be visually
appealing and provide valuable
information to your audience it is also
important to be authentic and true to
yourself like this okay so this is how
you can like using charge video how you
can create your marketing plans or your
something like that okay so our fifth
use cases we can generate articles and
blogs using chat GPT okay so let me ask
right and
article
Sheen
learning
because agility is also machine learning
kind of machine learning
on machine learning
and
500 Words
presenter
it will write only exactly like 500
Words it will give you only 500 like
machine learning is rapidly growing
field that is transforming the way we
live and work it is the branch of
artificial intelligence blah blah
basic idea of machine learning is that
computers can learn from data without
being explicitly programmed
like supervised learning is the most
common type of the machine learning just
through
yeah you can see here there are three
main types of machine learning
supervised learning and supervisor and
reinforcement
it's true
it will tell about like it will write a
proper
article in only 500 word not more than
that
in machine learning has a potential
application variants in healthcare
machine learning
patient data and more accurate diagnosis
like that
I wrote 500 Words
it will give you exactly 500 Words
that has the portion into the
emotionalize many Industries it allows
computers to learn from the data without
being explicitly programmed I'm leaving
this is 500 Words of article
okay you're gonna write article videos
descriptions blogs any kind of content
writing you can see
okay so let's do one more question in
the same so I will like give me
on
to write
okay skip for my YouTube
with Canon
YouTube channel YouTube shorts
videos
on Cyber
security
okay
so here is a short skip for funny
YouTube video on cyber security
like narrator
where every clip could be your last
exactly
so something like that
no one always use strong password like
password One Two Three or fourteen
now the tip number two never click on
suspicious link unless it's linked to be
to free pizza
see this is how you can create your
funny
how you can generate your content from
chargpt using chargpt okay
thanks for watching stay safe out there
please note that that's scripted just
for fun exactly we know and not mean to
be taken seriously it's important to
take cyber security seriously and follow
best practices to protect your personal
and professional data
okay
so this is how you can write
your make your content so easily like by
writing the title of the content so our
six use cases you can even Summarize the
book or article using child Liberty like
how I will write here summarize
the book
Believers travel
thank you
universally just
no word written by Jonathan Swift in
this the book tells the story of female
Gulliver a ship surgeon who becomes
Shipwrecked it will light only it will
summarize all about delivered travel
yeah in part one this happened
Oliver washes up on the island of
lilliputia exactly
would this happen and part through this
happen
because this is how you can summarize
any book any related to like educational
no world fiction any type of book or
article and blogs
okay whatever you want to summarize
okay it will run the book is being
commented on the Society of ship to one
time
okay so this is how you can Summarize
the book value master
our seventh use cases we can ask
interview question two using charity so
here I can ask how to answer
the
viewer
what
is
your
weakness
okay
so when answering the question it is the
best to be honest but also to frame your
answer in a positive way yeah exactly
for example you could say something like
I have a tendency to be perfectionate
and sometimes struggle with delegating
task however I have been working on this
learning like this you can ask any
question any interview type question
okay related to HR or technical anything
you can ask
so let's see
how
to
answer
the
web viewer
uh like where do you see yourself
in next
five years
okay
egg
so when answering this question it's
good idea to be align your answer with
the company's course and values yeah
exactly for example you could say
something like in five years I can see
myself going within the company and
taking more responsibility exactly
so this is how
you can ask any type of HR questions
you are facing off okay
so our next use cases
our eighth use cases we can develop apps
using charge gbt
okay yes we can develop apps using
chargeability like
I want
to
write
and Android
app that
shows
me
each stock
prices
as a
list
um
let's see Yahoo
API
okay
or how
can
I
do
like this so it will write up proper
Android app code
for you
foreign
project or it will give you a proper
idea how you can make a you know app
all these steps
from starting to the last
choose a view holder to hold the
reference of the views for each item in
the list
okay
it was asynchronous stars to fetch all
this step from starting to the end
this is a brief overview of the steps
and you will need to take a build
Android app
okay
okay so this is how you can like ask
anything to create
a
okay using any language plot Java python
any language okay so I repeat our ninth
use cases we can create our exercise
plan diet plan using chatgpt okay
so I would like my width is 25 okay
let's take
25 kg
and I want to
lose
create
seven days
create seven days
plan
for
the advice
I plan for it
okay
it will get see here is the day exercise
and the diet plan that can help you lose
day one exercise 30 minute risk walk or
joke right start your day with healthy
breakfast of oatmeal berries like this
it will create exactly seven days
okay so this is our ninth use case we
can make any type of plant diet plan
food plan exercise plan or anything
like marketing strategy
anything you want
timetable
uh focusing something anything you can
make
and according to you yourself you can
rearrange them okay it will be very easy
and it is very time saving
okay let me create seven days plan day
is X exercise training session like this
type
this you want to lose
avocado toast with pose that
is important to note that this is just a
plan Simple Plan
so our tense use cases last use case you
can ask any General Knowledge Questions
to charge it like
okay who invented
first
frustrated by German Goldsmith yeah
you can cross question to charge be the
answer okay
this is the all the use case of
charitability like
it can or debug the code audit the code
like explain complex subject create
custom marketing plan or strategy diet
plan exercise plan you can generate your
content like article blogs you can
Summarize the book and the Articles or
interview question preparation or
developing apps coding
you can easily do with the chat GPD okay
I hope you understand how to use chat
GPT and what is chat gbt okay and the
use cases of chat GPT and where you can
use in day-to-day life okay so so thank
you for watching this video till then
stay safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here